But Saturday out of the blue began tearing bubbly water, e-files, valid tools, and it continues
what this means from. So you're the one that asked the question about, then you started that
on Saturday and you ate cheese. So I think we kind of get that question. I mean, again,
hopefully you listen to my answer that there's some sort of inflammation going on, there's some sort
of reaction going on, could be a reaction to food, could be a reaction to, could be just an
inflammatory process going on and you're got, I just don't have a magic ball to answer that,
but those are the things you'd have to run some tests to see. If anything we can get out of this
call today is, you're going to try to measure things. So try to measure things without making,
getting wrong ideas. Yes, if you can't afford to do tests, then you could measure it by trying
to make some changes, like in a diet, elimination diet, to see if anything else changes.
Going back to this question about 30 pounds, too, is there something that's causing inflammation? It could
be something in your diet that even though you have a great diet, even though you have a great diet,
it doesn't mean that you're not eating something that is highly inflammatory and causing you to
gain weight. For instance, you know, I'm not a gluten-free diet, so I only eat gluten-free flour.
Well, maybe what's what's maybe tapioca starch, you have antibodies through the roof,
first, the happy equestarts. So every time you eat that, you're causing this huge inflammation
of the gut, you're not eating, you know, good absorption of nutrients and you might absorb macro
nutrients, you're just gaining weight, you're causing inflammation of the brain, it's shutting down
a whole bunch of different things. You have to measure things. So running a Cyrex array 10 might
be an order for you to see if it's something dietary that is causing inflammation. Remember, anything
inflammation of the gut is going to cause inflammation of the brain, it's going to affect two
traits, it's going to affect your hormones, it's going to affect a whole bunch of different things.
So, you know, I'm not against, like, you know, trying to do some different things, if that's what you
could do, but if you can measure things, it's much better. It's not just so we have high cortisol
levels, we could have low cortisol levels. Now, tell you how many people we've done on a adrenal
stress profile, and it's not that they have high cortisol levels, it's that they have no cortisol.
I mean, it's literally a flatline, it's because their adrenals are completely shocked. So,
we're going to do things to decrease cortisol levels, you're actually entering your body. So,
you know, if you could measure things, you're going to be better off. So, we can't measure everything,
but the things that you can measure, we're going to be better off, just like, okay, I'm high
homocysteine. So, we go on this, this is a lower homocysteine, and whoever asks that question could
rate thing, you're going through a process of, I used, that'll be 12 at lower than to this point,
and now it's just stubborn, it's staying there. Well, maybe we might need higher concentration,
maybe we might need to look at some other things. So, I always try to do that. I guess,
and I had Hashimoto's from the T-Trudus since about October, possibly. So,
but did you ever measure cyroglobulin antibodies or TPO antibodies prior to that? I don't know,
try to heal it by using styrofen-PMG and Iodoro, okay, wrong thing to do. Iodoro, you do not take iodine.
If you have primary type of thyroid isn't, or if you have Hashimoto's, we'd ever use iodine,
please go back, I gave everybody permission to get on the autoimmune course, go on the autoimmune
course, go to the last module on the autoimmune course, it's all about Hashimoto's. Please watch the
videos on that. You know, colleges told me core stories about not going on thyroid, on hormone
replacement, I really do not want to be on a bad liver, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah,
what your T-3 and T-4 levels are. So, if you want to send me those labs and it's kind of a
little appointment, we can pull over those. Do not take iodine when you have primary type of thyroid
ism, or Hashimoto's. So,